one of the coldest temperatures ever
recorded outside was negative 128
degrees fahrenheit in antarctica
one of the warmest temperatures ever
recorded outside was
134 degrees fahrenheit in death valley
california
how many degrees difference are there
between the coldest and warmest recorded
outside temperatures so let's think
about this a little bit and what i'll do
is i'll plot them on a number line but
i'm going to apply it on a vertical
number line that has a resemblance to a
thermometer since we're talking about
temperature so i'm going to make my
number line vertical right over here
so
there's my little vertical number line
and
this right over here is 0 degrees
fahrenheit which really is of no
significance if it was celsius we'd be
talking about the freezing point but for
fahrenheit that happens at 32 degrees
but let's say this is zero degrees
fahrenheit and let's plot these two
points so the one of the coldest ever
recorded temperatures was negative 128
degrees fahrenheit so let's say that's
right over here negative
this is negative 1
negative
128
degrees fahrenheit and the one of the
warmest temperatures ever recorded was
134 degrees this is a positive 134. so
it's about that far and a little bit
further so it's a positive
134 degrees fahrenheit so when they're
asking us
how many degrees difference are there
between the coldest and the warmest
they're essentially saying well what is
this distance between the coldest and
the warmest
between the coldest and the warmest
right over here what is this distance
and there's a couple of ways you could
think about it you could say hey if i
start at the coldest temperature and i
wanted to go all the way up to the
warmest how much would i have to add
or you could say well what's the
difference between the coldest and the
warmest so you could take the larger
number so let's say 134
and from that you could subtract the
smaller number you could subtract the
smaller number which is negative
negative 100 and right
negative 128.
so this is essentially saying what's the
difference between these two numbers is
going to be positive because we're
subtracting the smaller one from the
larger one this is going to give you the
exact same thing as this
now there's several ways to think about
it one is we know that if you subtract a
negative number that's the same thing as
adding the positive nu the positive of
that number or adding in the absolute
value so this is the same thing this is
equal to
this is going to be equal to
1
34
plus
plus
positive 128 degrees and what's the
intuition behind that why why does this
happen well look at this right over here
we're trying to figure out this distance
this distance is 134 minus negative 128.
and if you look at that it's going to be
the absolute value of 134 it's going to
be this distance it's going to be this
distance right over here which is just
134 which is just that right over there
plus
plus
this distance
right over here now what is this
distance well it's the absolute value of
negative 128 is just 128. so it's going
to be that distance 134 plus 128 and
that's why it made sense this way you're
thinking of what's the difference
between a larger number and a smaller
number but since the smaller numbers
you're subtracting a negative you're
really it's the same thing as adding the
positive and hopefully this gives you a
little bit of that intuition but
needless to say we can now figure out
what it's going to be
and this is going to be equal to let me
let me figure this out separately over
here so if i were to add 134 plus 128
plus
128
128
i get 4 plus 8 is 12
1 plus 3 plus 2 is 6. it's 262.
so it's 200 this right over here is
equal to 262. how many degrees
difference are there between the coldest
and the warmest recorded outside
temperature
262
degrees fahrenheit difference